[Music]
what's up my name's Samuel Lee you want
to get into rent to rent business you
want to rent a house like my boy Nile
does how much you're paying for this
house this is 1950 per month so you're
guaranteed to pay 1 950 pounds every
month that's it and then you rent it out
uh by the night a service accommodation
show us man show us
so you don't own this house where you
rent it that's right so this is dusk
house partnered with its sister Dawn
house which is around the corner we pay
roughly about the same for both
properties does you have to tell the
landlord what you're doing absolutely we
do in fact we insist that the landlord
knows all the ins and outs of the
business so that we have an open and
transparent relationship right from the
get-go why would the landlord let you
rent this out by the night when you
could be attracting parties and getting
the place trashed and maybe it won't run
out and then you like Oh Mr landlord I
can't pay you why would I not just run
into a family why are you to you it's a
much better deal for the landlord so we
aren't a regular tenant we're a
corporate elect so we have to be out
within 21 days if something goes wrong
here we pay a little bit above market
right now in okay I'm sold I'm sold this
one has two bedrooms and then the sofa
is a double pull out as well so you can
literally turn this into a bed yes
that's right
about to do it
see this man's making all this weight
you don't even know how to turn a sofa
into a bed but you just know that it can
be done yes so who does this who manages
all this stuff well I'm not the Hands-On
guy myself I'm all the numbers I can see
we do have a team that's on the ground
that comes here and manages maintenance
cleans how often do you have to come
here I haven't been here in about a
month and then this is kind of our
second bedroom so space for two singles
they push together well so you can make
that a double this folds out to a double
and it's got an ensuite here as well how
many bedrooms did you say it has this is
two bedrooms so when you wear this out
do you rent it out as a room by room or
do you just rent the whole house out no
we rent the whole house out so it tends
to be typically families that are doing
a broad travel and doing some tourism or
business trips that's where we are boom
but look what are we surrounded by
hotels right Hotel here 141 pounds a
night 113 pounds a night 185 pounds 107
pounds so there's all these hotels right
people paying 100 something 141 it's
literally yeah it's a stone throw so do
you think that Nile is gonna win this
property without doing any market
research no who's gonna do the market
research not just Niall he's going to
let the hotels do the market research
for him because you ain't going to be
spending 10 million pounds building a
hotel if you haven't researched the
market and know that there is demand for
hotels so you know there's a demand for
short stay let's absolutely why would
someone book this instead of booking one
of these hotels much better I mean it is
especially as I show you around their
house as well having kitchenettes coffee
machines your own living space place to
just relax and chill out as well is much
better than just a bed in a hotel room
you can book a hotel room for 140 pounds
but that's what's that a room
what's this multiple rooms with kitchens
and a lounge area and a sofa bed that
you can't turn into a sofa bed so how
much do charge plan our average nightly
writing this one for the month will
probably be between 260 and 300 this
month now and what's the occupancy right
we hover around 80 we're disappointed
with anything blowing 80. so he's paying
the landlord 1950 on this one 1950 so
about two thousand but he's charging
about 200 pound or not on average is
that fair to say higher than that I'd
say probably closer to 260 this month
2-6 day times that by 30 days a 7 800
and it's not fully occupied but he'd be
disappointed anything less than 80s 80
about average that's right yep that's 6
200. so you've got a six thousand two
hundred coming in you're giving the
landlord two thousand so how much profit
does this house make you a month this
one we're expecting two grand a month
and you've got how many properties have
you got like this this one is one of the
twin pair so this one and I'll show you
it's sister around the corner and then
we've got two apartments in the same
block as well so four just in this area
now all together making and roughly
twelve thousand pound profit per month
I'm just dead at that bro anyone would
look at you because they want to start
investing and if you were worried about
the return on investment for a pound for
a day's worth of your time compared to
the doors that'll open to you you're not
serious about investing in the first
place spend one pound come meet me
property investors crash course let's do
business let's make this happen but man
I'm so proud of you bro respect let's go
to the next house
[Music]
so this is your second house and you do
this is like a partnership with your
brother right yeah that's right I'm a
business partners with my brother on
this one that's what you want to do pull
people in pull people in because you can
only do so much on your own I actually
think this is nicer the last one it
swings around about really I think
everyone's got some more of a wow factor
in some respects but the space is a bit
nicer in this one I think as well
question why would people not do this if
you're making two grand a month per
property two grand a month is like a
full-time salary I think the interest to
be honest with you I think people just
don't want to put their money down and
take the chance sometimes because
there's a bit of money down right you've
got like the rents of the landlords
you've got deposit and you've obviously
spent money again this place furnished
and stuff like that so there's a little
bit of money but I tell you something
you would be hard-pressed to make two
grand a month profit from a buy to let
oh absolutely the only way you could
possibly do it would again be service
accommodation and you've got a whole
bunch of properties you've got buy to
lets you've got brrs yep and portfolio
here as well you know what as well I've
been trying to stay at Niles penthouse
for months it's fully booked I can't get
in the penthouse what's the occupancy
like 100 almost this month we're batting
for a perfect game so we are one night
short of doing 100 this month and what
do you charge per night at the penthouse
it would be similar to this so because
of the luxury standard it can't sleep as
many people but it's got the balcony
Terrace so somewhere between 200 and 500
pound average nightly rate is about 2 30
this month 230 pounds how bad has it
been we're gonna do 100 100 percent
which seven thousand pounds from your
Penthouse that's right in one month then
how much you ban the landlord that one
would pay in one seven fifty so you're
making a profit and for how much we're
going to be knocking on the door three
grand this month if not a touch over
I'm begging you to get into real estate
get into property and do this like I was
at the century do you remember how hard
I had to persuade you to go to the
academy you came to the crash course you
went for it was you skeptical when you
started I had made my mind up so I
wasn't but I had a lot of questions
before I put my money where my mouth is
and took the leap people say oh Samuel
gets people on a g-shot these guys are
paid actors am I paying you for the
video no absolutely you know paid actor
is a guy who left his job to go full
time in property because he just had a
young boy who's outside and wanted to
take Financial control of his own life
and now you've done that and you're
financially free that's right what was
your experience when you came out of the
crash course it was overwhelming but the
energy was the main takeaway I took from
it it was the first time I think I've
been in a room with that palpable
optimism of people just wanted to do it
yeah and as well like everything you're
doing is stuff that like we teach
absolutely step by step So when you say
about the risks downstairs if you follow
the plan you manage the risk you analyze
things the way that we're trying to I
mean you never have a nervous situation
to invest in but you can get as close to
zero as possible so come join me at the
property investors crash course I'll be
there in person tickets are how much one
pound is that ridiculous or what yeah
it's ridiculous one pound I'll leave a
link in the description see you there
[Music]